Happy birthday Mi-na!
You are now a year older!
What's your birthday wish?
Thank you, Alex.
My birthday wish is to get a job promotion this year.
Well, thank you so much for remembering my birthday and celebrating it.
That's very nice of you.
Don't mention it, that's what friends are for!
Did you have, what was it called, brown seaweed soup this morning?
I heard Koreans eat it on their birthdays.
Yes, because a woman who delivers a child needs to take lots of iron,...
...and brown seaweed or other seaweeds are rich in iron.
So that's why you eat brown seaweed soup on your birthday to commemorate birth.
Anyhow, how did you spend your last birthday?
It's such a shame that we don't have a culture like yours.
Oh well, back to your question.
My last birthday was absolutely crazy.
Guess what I got for a birthday present?
I got a car from my parents.
It was not a new car; it was used,...
...but the thing is, I didn't expect that my parents would spend that much money for my birthday.
Well, now, my brother is using it, so it became more like a family car,...
...but that was the best birthday gift ever!
That sounds very nice.
I wish my parents would do the same,...
...but for this year's birthday, I got a nice pair of shoes,...
...and I am very happy with them!